mário backpacks and an SLR mount for
your iphone it's episode 17 of loot
where your glasses and shades together
in one piece while browsing portal
necklaces aperture totes laptop stickers
and on and on and on and here's a book
that shows you how to build weapons out
of stuff you've got around the office or
classroom now that you're officially
awesome chew on some beef jerky potato
chips and rather than buying someone a
card for every occasion buy a bunch of
utility cards each cards word search
contains more than 100 wishes and
sentiments so just circle the ones that
apply to that person on that day with
all the time you save relax with a drink
in a doom glass while wearing literary
themed t-shirts Moby Dick the Bell Jar
tell-tale heart the Sun Also Rises and
more now what cats love chasing laser
pointers but why do all that difficult
hand movie when you could have the
frolic at Boalt do it for you the Museum
of Modern Art carries toast coasters and
a bubble necklace or make a bubble
necklace for free in the shower while
storing products on the showers squid
then clean your hands with some hand
soap no no some hand soap
once that are clean shove on some pickle
finger puppets while your pet finger
paints masterpieces with no mess thanks
to think deep which also offers a bacon
scented air freshener and chapstick
I mean spam flavored lip glaze charge
your phone in an emergency with this
solar powered USB charging pack that
gives you eight extra hours of power and
teach your baby something new thanks to
Tiffany art she designs X and Y
chromosome earrings as well as this baby
room picture that teaches not ABC's not
one two threes but prime numbers from
two ladybugs to 41 pieces of bacon to 53
snails before we run at a time let's
talk about time telling it complexly and
beautifully tokyo flash designs amazing
sci-fi watches that you'll know how to
read while confusing strangers and
attracting hot alien
ladies I leave you with some of nito
shops I heart shirts and not a free
thing but a free piece of historical
information what I like to call epic
gifts in history in 1865
Seth kenmin gave President Andrew
Johnson a chair a chair made out of a
bear who exactly was Seth Kidman well he
was a hunter who owned a bar and once
played fiddle for Abraham Lincoln you
know a fiddle that he made out of a mule
skull they're not yet available to buy
online but in the meantime as always
thanks for watching
you
[Music]
[Music]